how did we lock down in the first place
this this is amazing
and no one is talking about it because
it's so embarrassing the American
Institute for Economic Research I just
published this piece which genius
scientist with a big gray beard and a
lab coat who has degrees from Harvard
and MIT and which one do you think gave
us the idea for a lockdown oh it wasn't
any of them it was a 14-year old high
school girl yes
the idea for the lockdown as a response
to the epidemic came to us not from the
exalted dr. fowey not from the are
amazing soothsayer scientific priestly
class not even from the elected
politicians the 14 year old high school
girl 14 year old high school girl
who was the daughter of a scientist at
Sandia National Laboratories she devised
a computer simulation that showed how
people family members co-workers
students and schools people and social
situations interact so she builds the
computer model she discovered that
school kids come in contact with about
140 people a day which is more than any
other group based on that finding her
program showed that in a hypothetical
town of 10,000 people 5,000 would become
infected during a pandemic if no
measures were taken but only 500 would
be infected if the schools were closed
according to this high school girls
computer model the girls name which I
won't say because it's not her fault
that we created an international policy
based on a 14 year old girls science
model is I'm not not gonna say her name
but her name does appear on the
foundational paper arguing for lock
downs enforced human seperation that
paper is the targeted social distancing
designs for pandemic influenza from 2006
you know what this story reminds me of
this reminds me exactly of how we got
the bans on plastic straws that's
another hysteria that has caught on
around the country if not around the
world you remember back in the olden day
of like six months ago we used to have
plastic straws that we could use when we
would drink out of cups and then one day
they banned the straws for some reason
we had to use those stupid paper straws
that just turn into pulp and you have to
eat them how did that happen
was it because some scientist in a big
lab coat with a big gray beard who's you
know really super smart and educated
told us that we had to do it know was it
from some elected politicians
imagination no there's a nine-year-old
boy nine-year-old boy fourth grade boy
who did a school project tried to
estimate how many plastic straws people
use everyday called a few companies
tried to extrapolate from there and then
started a non-profit activist movement
to try to get people to not use straws
and then when that didn't work to try to
get the straws banned not based on
science you know science with a capital
S and a trademark over the not based on
the guys in the lab coat it's not even
based on the ethical and political
discussions among our elected
representatives and among ourselves no
fourth-grade boy
[Music]
[Music]